We're
going to see the elephant is a story
about a young man who believes
themselves to be the greatest writer in
the history of the world.
The only problem is he hasn't written
anything yet.
It's a.
it's a condition.
Many young writers find themselves in.
He moves to San Francisco because he
thinks of this as a romantic literary
city and a place for him to fulfill his
destiny.
And he gets a job,
sort of sweet.
Talks himself into a job at a place
called the morning trumpet,
which is a third rate newspaper,
whose,
you know,
heyday was probably an 1850 right after
the gold rush.
And it's been going downhill ever since.
Even still,
they think slater brown,
the name of this young man is something
wrong about it.
He just doesn't quite add up.
And so to get rid of him,
they say,
if you're such a hot writer,
go find us a story.
And they're pretty sure they'll never
see him again.
Uh,
he proceeds to go out into the city of
San Francisco to look for a story.
Uh,
and a series of things happened to them.
And in very short order,
he's the most powerful person in the
city.
And um,
that's,
that's the nuts and bolts of it.
But,
uh,
when I sat down,
people asked me how I came to this idea
and I was walking around San Francisco
one day about seven years ago and I saw
this guy,
I saw my character in a coffee shop and
that was the impetus for me to start to
tell this story.
And the same character is in Dallas
today.
He's in New Orleans,
he's in New York City's in London.
It's the romantic,
idealized young man or woman who is a,
been a passionate reader and had,
wants to be a writer and now is on the
process of figuring out how to get
there.
And that's really what the book's theme
is about on some level.
I don't think I'm probably a good judge
of my themes yet.
I think there's still emerging and I
don't think when I sit down to write,
I'm usually drawn in by something that
I've heard a,
whether it's a piece of dialogue or
maybe I've seen something.
And that's sort of the starting point,
when I started to write this book,
going to see the elephant,
I didn't know where the end was,
which was a huge mistake.
Uh,
and I also didn't know if I could do it.
I mean,
it's sort of like training for a
marathon.
You believe you can do it,
uh,
you want to do it,
but can you do it?
And this book,
uh,
was a process of me figuring out how to
do that and writing it was a huge leap
of faith for me.
But also,
you know,
as I said earlier,
perhaps a benign mental illness,
I feel like I'm themes are things that
are found after the fact and that most
writers don't consciously engage in that
or if they do,
I think sometimes their work suffers
because of that.
Uh,
I,
I find my entry point into these things
to be more around characters or a
particular feeling or mood and not a,
you know,
I want to write a story about coming of
age or something like that.